well there's there's there's lots of
evidence i mean especially
i don't know if you've researched done a
lot of research on graham hancock
and randall carlson he got graham
hancock
wrote a book called fingerprints of the
gods where he talks about those lost
civilizations that got wiped out
and basically he says there's multiple
cataclysmic events that happened
throughout the history of the earth
throughout the last six billion years
that aren't accounted for in
basically modern studies of history and
ice ages that aren't accounted for
and basically the basics the basic
summary of it is that
there were civilizations just as
advanced as us if not more advanced that
got wiped out
by crazy ice ages and comets that hit
the earth like there's com there's a
there was a a new meteorite location
in greenland i think it is where it's
like an 18 mile wide comet
wow that would have wiped out the earth
and seared the top of the planet
and there they also showed there's i
mean they have tons of youtube videos
and podcasts that actually detail this
so if you're if you're watching this
search graham hancock and randall
carlson
where they talk about it and they even
show detailed photos of
if you go to the beach and it's low tide
like right after the water goes back out
near the shore you'll see like those
ripples in the sand
where you know water was just there and
like current when current rips through
an area like in a river
you'll see ripples in the sand basically
what they show is in washington
when you fly over these great plains in
washington
there's these same exact ripples that
are
miles and miles and miles long
where basically he's what it proves his
theory that
there was massive you know sea level
changes where in one day the sea levels
would rise by 300 400 feet
because of these ice caps melting
because these comets would hit earth and
basically just
create instant an instant climate change
that would in one afternoon basically
raise the temperature of the earth
by who knows 100 degrees and the whole
top of the of the continent would be on
fire and it would
put it would add 400 to 300 feet of sea
water on top of whatever was just there
earlier that afternoon
sure that water rushes in i'm sure is
that yeah blows up and
the same thing what you see at the beach
with those little ripples in the sand or
in a river mouth those little ripples in
the sand underneath the water
so it's absolutely mind-blowing no like
i say man there's just there's still so
much
that we don't know you know even going
out to to uh utah
um and i've gone out there several times
we went out there with a family one year
and found
shells you know sea shells in a high
desert somewhere so you know you know
the water was up at that point
there was even a study here i want to
say about five years ago
and and they're always finding uh these
mastodon these little baby elephants and
whatnot throughout greenland
and um they end up finding one one day
that where the skin was still on it
was still had flesh and it was it had
been frozen
and the strange thing was that they you
know obviously the the scientists were
all excited they packed this little
animal up and they bring them back to
the lab
and they start looking at them and they
found him in a frozen environment
but the interesting thing was that the
contents of its stomach were still there
and they were buttercups and he said
when this animal was
killed he was in a field where there
were buttercups
so whatever change happened happened
it's a it's just a small plant that they
would eat okay like a grass plant
okay and um he said that whatever event
took place wherever this
this little baby mastodon elephant was
eating
um was hit by a wall of ice and covered
instantly so whether it was an
environmental change that happened right
now or it was a meteorite that struck
the planet
part of that event let's say that took
place that hit him but he was in a warm
environment before
right when he died and so when you look
at there's now scientists that are
looking at those events and going hey
listen
some of these events were catastrophic
they didn't just didn't happen over time
yeah they happened right now and so when
you look at those events like that
i could absolutely see that happening
yeah this guy randall carlson
talks about how during some of these
events
that icebergs the size of oil tankers
would be just sliding would just be
being
carried across the continent and those
icebergs are full of rock and debris at
the same time so when those things do
those things carry lots of rock
and lots of big debris and fragments so
when those things melted it explains why
all these rocks are now scattered in
places
right never be these hundred ton stones
were frozen in
these 1 000 ton icebergs or something
ridiculous i don't know the exact number
but these
massive icebergs that were bigger than
oil tankers just being
sliding across the earth and completely
just melting and powderizing anything in
its way
and like i said we're still seeing those
changes today if you look at how the
tides have come up here
just in florida there's areas you know i
grew up here
there's areas um where i used to go
fishing at down by
the shoreline and today at high tide
those areas flood
and they didn't flood when i was a kid
so these these events are definitely
happening there's changes going on
whether it's you know related to the sun
or to environmental whether we're doing
it you know becomes a whole other story
i think they're naturally occurring
events that take place
i watched a program the other night that
talked about alien beings and he said
what they
they start talking about giving us the
different types of blood
types that we have a positive o a
negative
look at these different blood types and
those blood types were given to us so
that if they
at any one point in time they didn't
like that what was going on with that
group of people
they could develop a bug that would
after just those that blood type
and would kill them off where did you
watch this so they were talking well
they started talking about the the
the big plague the bubonic plague oh
okay and they said
so when you look at these catastrophic
events throughout
history that take mankind out they only
take out a certain group
and as fast as they come in they leave
again and so
he said what he believed was that
the planet is a living entity and that
we're kind of like a bacteria on it and
for the last
thousands and thousands of years uh the
extraterrestrials have been
grooming us and trying to get us to do a
certain thing
and every time we wouldn't do that
certain thing they would come through
and kind of wipe us out so if you
if you go back and look at the history
of mankind you think well man the great
flood they talk about in the bible and
the bubonic plague and the spanish
flu and all these different events that
come through and kill just hundreds and
hundreds of millions of people
um said were brought on on purpose by
extraterrestrial beings
well another thing to consider is
there's as far as like these big
cataclysmic events that happen that
wipe out civilizations and then wipe out
the face of the earth
there's for instance there's this thing
called the
media or the uh the torrid meteor stream
which is basically this freaking
it's this like million mile wide
stream of meteors and comets that the
earth
actually passes through twice a year
okay
i think it's once in june and once in
november
and apparently the equivalence
of the earth passing through this stream
and not getting
hit by a eight mile wide
comet is the equivalence of you putting
on a blindfold and
walking and running across a six-lane
highway praying you don't get hit by a
truck
my luck's not that good by the way yeah
[Laughter]
but he was basically claiming that the
earth passes through this thing twice a
year
and there's a handful of comets in that
meteor stream
the taurid meteor stream that are big
enough
to completely wipe out the face of the
earth
so it's only a matter of time before one
you know before one of those comets hits
the earth again and just
and just completely destroys the earth
and everything that all every living
thing
now did you see this this this um meteor
that came in
through russia i want to say it was
three or four years ago was actually one
that came in through
garbowsk russia and in the process of
actually coming down to the ground
something hit it yeah it exploded well
what i think what happened was
it went the atmosphere basically burned
it up and it
exploded in the air before it hit the
ground right well what they do is they
actually show something that actually
what's that thing called again flies up
to
it and hits it and they actually give
this thing
credit for that thing not hitting the
earth well again listen if this is a
living
and let's go with this for a second
let's just say the planet is a living
entity
and when i when i ask one of the guys
who's put on the class well let me ask
you this okay let's just say that you're
right
and that we were given blood types for
that reason and and we're we are a
bacteria
yeah what's the what's the what's the
focus i mean what is our
what is our what are we supposed to do
and
he said listen we've done it and we've
mastered it and it's carbon dioxide
we now put more carbon dioxide in the
history of mankind
and he goes if you if he goes i said
well why would you say that he said well
the reason i say that is because there's
more people on the planet now than ever
recorded history
right if they if we weren't doing the
right things
he goes they'd get rid of us because
it's not healthy for the planet and so
everything comes back to the planet i
said so you don't think
these are from other worlds and he's
like oh no
they've always been right here they're
again their primary function is to make
sure that the planet stays healthy
and on its game
i